[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend ihnen allen
und willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem Samstag die vom Sport hat
Norbert Lehmann mit Fußball Bundesliga
der Frauen oder Männer wir haben unter
anderem diese Themen für Sie
ein Hauch von Wahlkampf auf dem
CSU-Parteitag beschwört Gastredner März
Einigkeit und teilt gegen die Ampel aus
Attacke vor den Zwischenwahlen in den
USA befeuert der Angriff auf Nancy
pilosis Ehemann die Angst vor
politischer Gewalt
und eine Stunde geschenkt heute Nacht
wird die Uhr auf Winterzeit
zurückgestellt hilft das beim
Energiesparen
[Musik]
die Union läuft sich warm für die
nächsten Wahlen im kommenden Jahr in
Bayern mit scharfen Attacken gegen die
Bundesregierung begeisterte CDU-Chef
Merz die Delegierten auf dem
CSU-Parteitag die Ampelkoalition mache
Deutschland auf der ganzen Welt
lächerlich sagt Merz Scholz sei der
respektloseste Bundeskanzler aller
Zeiten aus Augsburg Alexander Pohl
irgendwann muss es Markus Söder bemerkt
haben sein Gast Friedrich Merz bekommt
während seiner Rede mehr Applaus als
Söder in seiner Mercedes Sport lasst uns
zusammenhalten lasst uns stark sein
nicht gleich wieder fallen lassen ja
geht es gerade gut los März erinnert an
das vergangene Jahr zerstritten über die
Frage der Kanzlerkandidatur landet die
Union bei der Bundestagswahl beim
schlechtesten Ergebnis ihre Geschichte
das war nicht so weil die anderen so gut
waren
sondern das war weil wir nicht mehr gut
genug war und weil sich das Jahr 2021
nicht wiederholen soll nimmt der
CDU-Chef in seiner Rede den größten
gemeinsamen Gegner ins Visier die
ampelregierung von Olaf Scholz wir
hatten noch nie einen Bundeskanzler in
Deutschland der so respektlos umgegangen
ist mit seinen Koalitionspartnern so
respektlos umgegangen ist mit den
Institutionen unseres Staates so
respektlos umgegangen ist mit unseren
Nachbarn Respektlosigkeit steht über
dieser Kanzlerschaft und auch sonst
regiere in Berlin das Chaos so März
Beispiel die cannabis-freigabe die der
Bundesgesundheitsminister plant
was hat der Mann eigentlich geraucht
oder das Machtwort das Kanzlers drei
Atomkraftwerke bis April weiterlaufen zu
lassen wir machen uns auf der ganzen
Regierungschef lächerlich hier sind sich
die einstigen Rivalen einig zusammen
könnten sie es besser
mitten in der Energiekrise steckt die
Metall- und elektro-branche im
Tarifkonflikt die dritte
Verhandlungsrunde endete schon nach 50
Minuten die
IG Metall fordert für rund 3,9 Millionen
Beschäftigte rund 8% mehr Geld das
Angebot der Arbeitgeber eine
Einmalzahlung von 3000 Euro und eine
noch nicht bezifferte Lohnerhöhung für
die Gewerkschaft ist das eine
Provokation in reihenform Christina
iglseder berichtet kaum ist er
Mitternacht die Friedenspflicht in der
Metall- und Elektrobranche abgelaufen da
kommen sie in Hannover schon vors
Werkstor vier Jahre lang gab es keine
Lohnerhöhung jetzt wollen Sie endlich
mehr Geld im Portemonnaie die Forderung
8%. wenn ich einkaufen gehe ist der
Wagen für 100 Euro noch nicht mals Teil
befüllt man kann kaum noch die
Strompreise und die Gaspreise bezahlen
aber auch die Unternehmen
ächzen unter den hohen Kosten können
Preissteigerungen nur bedingt
weitergeben die durch den ukraine-krieg
seien unkalkulierbar daher kein
konkreter Vorschlag für eine
Lohnerhöhung das Angebot der Arbeitgeber
lediglich eine Einmalzahlung von 3000
Euro über eine Laufzeit von zweieinhalb
Jahren wir sollten im Hintergrund haben
dass die Abarbeitung von Aufträgen nicht
automatisch zu Umsatz und gewinnen
insbesondere führt weil viele Aufträge
auch zu Festpreisen vor dem Krieg
vereinbart wurden die faktisch heute bei
der Abarbeitung zu Verlust führen hohe
Forderungen könnten zudem die
lohn-preisspirale weiterdrehen die
Inflation erst recht anheizen ein
Argument das die Gewerkschaft aber nicht
gelten lässt die Löhne sind ja noch gar
nicht gestiegen die Preise sind aber
schon explodiert und jetzt geht es darum
dass wir Lösungen brauchen wie die
Beschäftigten mit diesen gestiegenen
Preisen klarkommen und deswegen wenn die
Preise steigen müssen auch die Löhne
steigen die Positionen liegen so weit
auseinander wie lange nicht die
Warnstreiks heute möglicherweise der
Auftakt für einen harten Arbeitskampf
eigentlich sollte er 30 Jahre geheim
bleiben der Bericht des hessischen
Verfassungsschutzes über den nsu-terror
jetzt haben ihnen das ZDF-Magazin Royale
und die Plattform fragt den Staat
veröffentlicht zur Erinnerung zwischen
2000 und 2007 ermordete das NSU Trio um
Böhnhardt Mundlos und tschepad 10
Menschen lange blieben die Morde
ungeklärt die Rechtsextremisten
unentdeckt auch weil Behörden versagten
der NSU Bericht aus Hessen jetzt also
frei zugänglich Susanne Santina für den
hessischen Verfassungsschutz kam die
Veröffentlichung der nsu-akten nicht
überraschend er wurde vorab informiert
man sei nun im Hinblick auf Staatswohl
belangem Austausch mit der Polizei teilt
die Behörde und schriftlich mit versteht
nun sind Akten für jeden einsehbar die
in Hessen erst für 120 Jahre dann für 30
Jahre geheim bleiben sollten so heißt es
darin zum Beispiel das zahlreiche
Hinweise auf haufenbesitz von
Rechtsextremisten an vielen die in der
Regel nicht bearbeitet worden waren ein
klares Versagen sagt eine so watch dass
der Verfassungsschutz weiß dass ich die
Neonaziszene bewaffnet und zwar
kontinuierlich bewaffnet und der
Verfassungsschutz nichts dagegen tut er
verhindert ist nicht er fragt nicht nach
er entwaffnet die Szene nicht und er
zerschlägt die Strukturen nicht über
viele Jahre konnten Neonazis zehn
Menschen ermorden außerhalb des Radars
der Verfassungsschützer das
rechtsradikale nsu-trio enttarnte sich
schließlich selbst und die Hintermänner
ungeklärt bis heute der Fall von
halidowska in Kassel ein Mitarbeiter des
hessischen Verfassungsschutzes war zur
Tatzeit am Tatort und will nichts
gesehen haben es gibt viele offene
Fragen zu diesem Mord die nsu-akten
beantworten sie nicht versteht aber auch
rund 200 Aktenstücke sind nicht mehr
auffindbar
nach dem NSU ja versprochen wurde es
gebe Transparenz und Aufklärung das gab
es nicht wir wissen dass viele Akten
geschreddert wurden und alleine dass man
einen Bericht auf 120 später in 30
Jahren geheimeinstuft er zeigt ja dass
man überhaupt kein Interesse an
Transparenz und Aufklärung hat
dirigierenden CDU und Grünen in Hessen
sehen durch die Veröffentlichung der
nsu-akten den Schutz von Informanten
gefährdet viele Angehörige der Opfer
sprechen dagegen von einem wichtigen
Schritt in Richtung Aufklärung
immer wieder hat Russland gedroht man
werde das Abkommen zum Export von
ukrainischen Getreide übers Schwarze
Meer platzen lassen wenn es Sabotageakte
gebe jetzt hat Moskau seine Teilnehmer
Teilnahme tatsächlich ausgesetzt
offizieller Grund die russische
Schwarzmeerflotte soll von der Ukraine
mit Drohnen angegriffen worden sein und
zwar auch Schiffe die zum Schutz der
Getreideexporte im Einsatz sein heißt es
gehört als Sprecherin des
Repräsentantenhauses zu den mächtigsten
PolitikerInnen der USA jetzt besteht die
Sorge dass sie kurz vor den
Zwischenwahlen möglicherweise Ziel eines
Anschlags werden sollte gestern brach
ein Mann in ihr Haus in San Francisco
ein und verletzte ihren Ehemann schwer
die 82-jährige Demokratin selbst war
nicht zu Hause aus Washington Claudia
Bates
der Täter kam nachts durch die gläserne
Terrassentür schlug mit einem Hammer auf
den 82-jährigen Paul pelosy ein er
verlangte die Vorsitzende des
Repräsentantenhauses zu sehen wo ist
Nancy rief er doch sie war in Washington
deswegen war ihr Haus in San Francisco
nicht bewacht die Polizei hat keine
Zweifel dass der Anschlag ihr galt das
war eine gezielte Tat und das ist falsch
jeder sollte davon angewidert sein
der Einbrecher wurde festgenommen ein
Anhänger von Ex-Präsident Trump der im
Internet Antisemitismus und
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitete Nancy
Pelosi ist eine Hassfigur der
politischen Rechten wird seit Jahren von
Trump und seinen Anhängern verteufelt
beim Angriff aufs Kapitol haben
Umstürzler gezielt Jagd auf sie gemacht
und drangen in ihr Büro ein in ihrer
Wahlwerbung nehmen Republikaner sie ins
Visier das politische Klima ist
vollständig vergiftet
genug ist genug ist genug jeder Mensch
mit einem gewissen muss sich klar und
unmissverständlich gegen politische
Gewalt Stellen ganz gleich auf welcher
Seite man steht
stattdessen aber bezeichnen
rechtspopulistische Medien die Gewalttat
flugs als stage als inszeniert Angriffe
auf Politiker beider großer Parteien
haben sich in den letzten Jahren
vervielfacht in drei Monaten zählten
Behörden 1.800 Vorfälle aber auch die
Gewalttat gegen Paul Pelosi wird an den
tiefen politischen Gräben nichts ändern
wichtige Stichwahl morgen in Brasilien
es geht um den künftigen Präsidenten in
einem letzten TV-Duell beschimpften sich
beide Kandidaten der rechtsextreme
Amtsinhaber boltonaro und seinen linke
Herausforderer Ex-Präsident Lula da
Silva Beschuldigten sich erneut
gegenseitig der Lüge inhaltlich gab es
wenig Neues beim ersten Wahlgang Anfang
Oktober hatte Lula vorn gelegen
allerdings weniger deutlich als erwartet
in Iran haben die revolutionsgarten die
Regierungsgegner vor weiteren Protesten
gewarnt heute sei der letzte Tag der
Unruhen die Demonstranten sollten die
Geduld des Systems nicht
überstrapazieren sagte ihr Kommandeur
davon unbeeindruckt gingen wieder
landesweit tausende Menschen auf die
Straße
unbestätigten Berichten zufolge soll es
auch Tote und Verletzte gegeben haben
jetzt ein Blick in die Türkei in kaum
einem anderen Land steigen die Preise
derzeit schneller viele Menschen kommen
mit ihrem Geld kaum noch klar immer mehr
junge denken darüber nach auszuwandern
gleichzeitig will Präsident Erdogan nach
20 Jahren an der Macht auch die Wahlen
im kommenden Sommer gewinnen und trotz
Krise stehen seine Chancen gar nicht so
schlecht gerade versucht er mit dem
ersten E-Auto der Türkei zu punkten Jörg
Brase pünktlich zum 99 geburtstag der
türkischen Republik leistet der
Präsident gebotshilfe für sein neuestes
Prestigeobjekt das erste Auto aus
türkischer Produktion ein modernes
E-Mobil namens Talk seine Botschaft zum
Nationalfeiertag das türkische Volk ist
zu allem fähig
der Wagen den ihr hier seht ist ein
gemeinsamer Traum den wir seit 60 Jahren
Träumen hier der weiße hier der rote
Wagen ihr wisst das sind die Farben der
Türkei
Erdogans Traum ist es auch den 100
Jahrestag als Präsident und Erbe des
Republik Gründers Atatürk zu begehen
doch ob er die Wahl im nächsten Sommer
gewinnen kann ist völlig offen das Volk
leidet unter einer rekordinflation der
Unmut über die hohen Preise ist groß
dass er die Wahlen verlieren könnte
deshalb versucht er Visionen zu
verkünden und dafür nutzt er alle Medien
die unter seiner Kontrolle stehen
gestern erst hatte Erdogan diese
Visionen vorgestellt und damit wohl den
Wahlkampf eröffnet eine Mega-Show im
Sportpalast von Ankara mit Botschaften
an seine konservativen Wähler eine neue
Verfassung soll es geben die muslimische
Frauen schützen und offenbar die rechte
sexueller Minderheiten einschränken soll
die Verfassungsänderung soll die Rechte
auf Bildung und Arbeit für unsere
Mädchen und Frauen sicherstellen die das
muslimische Kopftuch tragen wollen und
sie soll unsere Familien vor der
Bedrohung durch perverse Strömungen
schützen
Vertreter der Opposition blieben der
Eröffnung des autowerks heute fern auch
das sei eine reine polit-show sagten sie
für Wahlkampfhilfe für den Präsidenten
stünden sie nicht zur Verfügung
es ist mal wieder soweit aus Sommer wird
Winterzeit um Energie zu sparen hieß es
als die Zeitumstellung vor über 40
Jahren eingeführt wurde wobei der Effekt
schwer messbar ist und viele sich jedes
Mal wieder Fragen vor oder zurück
also Entschuldigung morgen Nacht wird
die Uhr von drei auf zwei zurückgedreht
wir können anders gesagt etwas länger
schlafen Claudia Oberst
im Uhrenmuseum in Püttlingen steht die
Zeit niemals still sie einfach zurück zu
drehen für Klaus Hoffmann undenkbar die
Schätze aus fünf Jahrhunderten sind
technisch dafür gar nicht gemacht da hat
ja niemand dran gedacht dass das man
notwendig wird die zurück zu drehen und
alle Uhren die ein Schlagwerk haben
haben auch ein Rechen oder Zählwerk das
dabei verbogen würde deshalb darf man
das nicht machen seit 1980 gibt es in
Deutschland Sommer und Winterzeit
Auslöser die Ölkrise damals genau wie
heute musste man Energie sparen und
hoffte den Stromverbrauch spürbar zu
senken das hat sich nicht bestätigt da
gibt es mehrere wissenschaftliche
Studien zu wir haben auch eine Studie
angefertigt und haben uns angeschaut den
Stromverbrauch privater Haushalte und da
hat sich gezeigt dass die Zeitumstellung
selber kein Vorteil hat die Experten
kamen oft gerade mal 0,78%
Ersparnis die Umstellung macht also
wirtschaftlich wenig Sinn
EU-Kommission und Parlament wollen sie
abschaffen weil sie bei vielen Bürgern
extrem unbeliebt ist
allerdings kann man sich nicht einigen
welches System man denn jetzt dauerhaft
haben möchte also dauerhaft Winterzeit
oder dauerhaft Sommerzeit da gehen die
Interessen sogar in Deutschland
auseinander
umstritten wie sie ist einen Vorteil hat
die Zeitumstellung der morgige Sonntag
ist wunderbare 25 Stunden lang
ja immerhin jetzt Fußball Bundesliga
Norbert das Topspiel der Frauen ja
Hoffenheim gegen Frankfurt und verpasste
die Eintracht den Sprung an die
Tabellenspitze nach vier Siegen in Folge
nur ein 3:3 Unentschieden im
Verfolgerduell mit den tsg-frauen
Frankfurt bleibt weiter Hoffenheim
erstmal Vierter
in der 13 Minute erzählt Sophia klein
Herne für Frankfurt das 1:0 Geraldine
Reuteler verdoppelt den Vorsprung eine
knappe Viertelstunde später wohl die
meisten der 1200 Zuschauer sind dann
erleichtert als Nicole Billag kurz
darauf der Anschlusstreffer für das Heim
Team gelingt doch die Ernüchterung folgt
postwendend Laura Freigang trifft zum
3:1 für Frankfurt bei Halbzeit die
Chancenverwertung der Hessinnen kann
sich sehen lassen
doch dann kommt Katharina naschenweng
die österreichische Abwehrspielerin wird
zur Torjägerin 67 Minute der
Anschlusstreffer 7 Minuten vor Schluss
genauso konsequent
der Ausgleich sogar der Sieg ist für
Hoffenheim noch drin doch Melissa Kößler
verzieht in der Nachspielzeit es bleibt
beim 3:3 Hoffenheim verhindert
Frankfurts Sprung an die Tabellenspitze
in der Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer da
hat Bayern München zumindest für einen
Tag die Tabellenführung übernommen durch
den klaren Sieg gegen Mainz hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des 12 Spieltags
München gegen Mainz 6:2 Stuttgart
schlägt Augsburg mit einem Last-Minute
2:1 Leipzig bezwingt Leverkusen mit 2:0
Wolfsburg siegt 14:0 gegen Bochum das
Abendspiel Frankfurt trifft auf Dortmund
bereits gestern gewann Bremen gegen
Hertha mit 1:0 und morgen noch die drei
Sonntagsspiele die Tabelle Bayern also
an der Spitze Union könnte aber morgen
wieder an den Münchnern vorbeiziehen
Freiburg Dritter vor Frankfurt Leipzig
und Dortmund Werder klettert auf Platz 7
die zweite Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
Gladbach ja und unten tauschen
Leverkusen und Stuttgart die Plätze
Bayer jetzt 16 Bochum bleibt Vorletzter
Schalke könnte morgen mit dem neuen
Trainer Thomas Reis die rote Laterne an
den VfL übergeben
das Abendspiel Frankfurt gegen Dortmund
ausführlich bei uns zu sehen im
Aktuellen Sportstudio um 23 Uhr zu Gast
bvb-nationalspieler Nico Schlotterbeck
zur Formel 1 da hat Mercedes Pilot
George Russell beim Großen Preis von
Mexiko im freien Training die Bestzeit
erzielt der Brite anderthalb Sekunden
schneller als das Ferrari Duo Carlos
science und Charlie Clare Weltmeister
Max Verstappen wurde 6 Sebastian Vettel
schafft es nur auf Position 13
Luise wansa und Philipp Autenried das
sind Deutschlands erste
mixed-weltmeister in der olympischen
470erjolle die Hamburger Steuerfrau und
ihr bayerischer forschotergewannen vor
der Küste Israels die Goldmedaille mit
11 Punkten Vorsprung von Spanien Bronze
gegen an Frankreich
das war zum Sport kommt mal an vielen
Dank zum Schluss noch ein Weltrekord aus
der Schweiz so viel Passagierzug gab es
nämlich noch nie
100 Waggons 1,9 Kilometer Länge und
sieben Lokführer die gleichzeitig
Beschleunigen und Bremsen mussten der
Höhepunkt die Fahrt über ein Viadukt
zwischen Alpengipfel im Kanton
Graubünden
das Wetter wird morgen warm und oft
sonnig die Details hat gleich Christa
Orban um Viertel vor elf begrüßt sie
annegalinek im heute-journal und hier
übernimmt morgen mitrisirin machen sie
sich noch ein schönes Wochenende alles
Gute und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend ja so warm so spät im Jahr
das ist im Moment wirklich
außergewöhnlich auch in Spanien und in
Frankreich gab es heute wieder
Temperaturen bis 30 Grad und an etlichen
Stationen in Südengland 20 Grad und mehr
der Klimawandel verschiebt die
Jahreszeiten in der neuen Woche und zu
Monatswechsel da gehen die Temperaturen
aber ordentlich zurück mal wieder in den
Normalbereich und heute Nacht da gehen
die Temperaturen zurück auf 15 bis 6
Grad die dichtesten Wolken gibt es noch
im Nordosten anfangs mit etwas Regen
dann lockert es oft auf stellenweise
gibt es aber dichten Nebel und der muss
sich dann morgen vor allem in den Fluss
Niederungen erst einmal auflösen dann
scheint aber häufig die Sonne es ziehen
auch weniger Ruhe und Mittel hohe
Wolkenfelder durch als heute insgesamt
gibt es also oft einen goldenen
Oktobertag erneut mit Temperaturen
zwischen 16 von 25 Grad und dann kommt
eben diese neue Woche und der
Monatswechsel mit etwas mehr Wolken und
Regen mit etwas Wind vor allem zu
Wochenmitte hin vor allem aber diesen
sinkenden Temperaturen und der Oktober
verabschiedet sich dann wohl als der
wärmste seit Aufzeichnungsbeginn 1881
und damit verabschieden wir uns vom
wetter-team wir wünschen noch ein
schönes Wochenende